hi leute ich bin schon voll schick
angezogen und sonst was die habe auch
erst acht uhr morgens aber ich bin schon
ziemlich früh aufgestanden extra noch
ein video zu machen bevor ich zu einem
termin fahren bestimmt sich schon im
titel es geht um super mario ran
ich würde sagen nach pokémon ball
wahrscheinlich dass meist geheim obi lhe
spiel was es dieses jahr gibt oder geben
wird man spielt einfach mario mario
läuft von selbst man kann springen und
das krasse ist die erweiterung kostet
zehn euro für die plattform ios in zehn
euro halt echt jede menge wenn man mal
überlegt zur andere mario spiele kosten
eigentlich immer mindestens auch so viel
ich gehe jetzt einfach mal der sache auf
den grund ob sich das lohnt oder nicht
so ich habe jetzt mal die letzte welt
gemacht nicht wundern ich habe nicht so
viele von diesen lila münzen gesammelt
einfach nur mal kurz aus getestet und es
gibt insgesamt 24 welten nämlich die
alles täuscht nun alle welten ab 1 bis 4
sind erst spieler wenn du sie gekauft
hast dann kann man sie austesten so für
20 sekunden
oder man kauft sie ich kaufe jetzt weil
es keine rechtfertigung für mich selbst
nehme ich dass ich das video hier mache
du möchtest du welten 1649 euro 99
kaufen liebend gerne kaufen einkauf war
erfolgreich 10 euro habe ich jetzt
einfach dafür ausgegeben um bum bum bum
bum okay leute es wird alles frei
geschaltet gerade und wenn du dann ich
hab keine nintendo kann also wir spielen
jetzt einfach mal dass das frei erzeugt
ich muss sagen es kommt jetzt nicht so
übertrieben gut also dass nicht nur ich
den eindruck habe oder ob es tatsächlich
so ist aber es kommt einfach wirklich
nicht so krass gut an wie pokemon gau am
anfang und bei pokemon gehalt das ding
das war ein neues spielprinzip bzw
ingres hatte das feuer auch schon aber
es war doch ein relativ neues
spielprinzip es war einfach irgendwie
ganz netz oder mal was neues zu haben
und diese endlich renner sind ungefähr
so alt wie smartphones selbst also
dieses prinzip r läuft von selbst ja das
war es eigentlich aber man muss sagen
super mario
durch diese geilen mario grafiken
einfach ist schon extrem aufgewertet so
bisher
ich glaube es ist wirklich einfach ganz
simpel dass man halt alle welten spielen
kann dass man durch die zehn euro
bekommen und dafür ist schon jede menge
kohle also nintendo lanka schon
ordentlich zu kennt es jetzt der erste
boss kampf
sehr spektakulär
na gut es wird bestimmt noch schwerer
sag ich mal
aber so ist mario da immer diese pause
kämpfte über der lava wurde dann
irgendwann reinfeldt ich meine ich finde
es irgendwie weil das gehört zu mario
dazu ich persönlich weiß auch halb weil
ich das früher immer gespielt habe ich
denke mal jeder von euch hat
wahrscheinlich auch früher mario
gespielt wo zurück denn gibt also man
hat erst noch rallye tickets bekommen
da kannst du online zocken gegen andere
leute habe ich noch nie ausgetestet
ja ich will da erstmal nicht anteilig
ich beschränke mich jetzt einfach mal
auf dem in anführungszeichen offline
singleplayer-modus weil man muss ja eine
verbindung haben wir uns super mario
land spielt trügerische türen also es
sind schon spieler elemente die man
davor nicht hatte einfach dass man
durchs band das hat man auch schon in
dem in den preview natürlich gesehen es
ist eine nette geschichte muss man schon
sagen ich denke mal wenn ich jetzt nicht
dieses video darüber machen würde würde
ich aber nicht dafür zehn euro ausgeben
also natürlich ich hab so als youtuber
ein interesse daran euch so ein video zu
bringen euch zu sagen
lohnt sich das lohnt sich das nicht
hoffe mal dass euch das video auch
irgendwie interessiert okay ich mag es
macht schon gut fand so muss man sagen
aber wenn man jetzt nicht so der größte
mario fan aller zeiten ist dann glaube
ich würden werden nicht allzu viele
bereits sein da so viel man ihr ein zu
investieren also zähne einfach nur um
ein paar andere level zu spielen die man
für 10 euro kannst du dir wahrscheinlich
dass ihr wahrscheinlich fünf andere
endlich ran wir auch kombiniert länger
trocken kannst im app store kaufen
okay ich bin aber auch extrem schlägt
man eine lila münze ist mein ernst
man hat irgendwie schon so leicht in
ehrgeiz dass man da noch probiert sachen
zu bekommen also mit dem spielen gerade
verliebt ich mich aber auch mehr und
mehr so ein bisschen in die level
designs bis jetzt auch meine allererste
meinung dazu
ob sich dieser kauf lohnt oder nicht
aber ich würde einfach sagen wenn ihr
mario fans seid dann werden euch die
zehn euro das wahrscheinlich wert sein
so als normale spieler
ich denke mal da ist es halt auch ganz
nett wenn man einfach die drei tests
maps spielt und wenn ich meine es ist ja
bei apps immer so manche apps machen
einfach verdammt wichtig und falls das
so eine ist bei euch dann könnt ihr
nichts anderes tun als es zu kommen was
ich halt hart finde ist
wie extrem nintendo ja jetzt also was
für maßnahmen die ergriffen um dem
vorzubeugen das so spiele illegal
runtergeladen werden also bezieht dieses
spiel wo gebt euch ich habe schon
versucht gut wie alle münzen
ich glaube das wird ihm guttun hier es
hat schon wirklich was extrem cooles
mario einfach auf dem motto ist heute so
viele münzen
wir sind alle weg wenn eigentlich echt
schlecht darin diese münzen zu holen
aber ja doch ich gehe noch mal raus aus
dem spiel
also ich persönlich wäre das definitiv
wird sich durch zocken es gab ja auf
dieses labs world für fürs iphone was
sowie mario war er halt simple grafik
und nicht von nintendo ich finde es ein
bisschen schade bei super mario an dass
man diese 1 click steuerung hat dass man
es mit einer hand spielen kann dass
mario automatisch trend weil von der
leistung her würde man halt auf dem
iphone das dickste mario game überhaupt
bringen können oder zumindest ein cooles
sage ich mal weil man kann ja auch mit
diversen emulatoren nintendo ds game zu
wasser lag frei einfach hier drauf
spielen auf dem gerät also die die
leistung und sowas sind halt da deshalb
finde ich ein bisschen schade wenn man
so einen großen hype um das ding macht
dass es erstens so viel geld kostet und
man zweitens waren richtig cool designt
ist aber halt dann auch ein bisschen
mageres dir sage ich mal bekommt dann
hoffe ich einfach das video hat euch
gefallen wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder
und wie gesagt verlinkt ich euch noch
einmal das video vom letzten mal
da war ich nämlich mit meiner schwester
den ganzen tag in frankfurt ich musste
alles machen was sie wollte und das war
ja ihr seht selbst
ok dann macht's mal gut leute wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal und tschüss